please
help my online store so i got a great
question for one of my youtube viewers
love you guys rihanna who wrote in to
say what if i have an
online store and not an actual store
then what do you do
this is a great question rihanna thank
you so much for writing in i have three
suggestions
to help you market your online store
number one is lead with your values
this is so important i need to know what
it is that you stand for because
the challenge with a lot of online
stores is you're selling the same stuff
right you're selling the exact same
product that i can get at a thousand
other websites so why am i gonna buy
from you
instead of somebody else you have two
options you either
compete on price which is a race to the
bottom which is
you know you're making pennies in
profits
or you compete on values and values is
i'm buying into an experience
i'm buying into a company that's trying
to make the world a better place
and you need to show me how you're doing
that so an example that i want you to
look at
is honest.com and i've talked about them
a few times on this channel
they are an online retailer they have
over 100 million dollars in sales
and they believe in honest
they have products that are honestly
made that don't have chemicals in them
that are all natural that are organic
that the suppliers treat their people
in a humane way right they
care about honesty
and so some people will go to that
website and and say honest is a stupid i
don't care about that you know
i just want the cheapest product and
that's fine you're going to lose out on
those customers but there are other
customers who are going to come
and they'll see that and they'll love it
and say yes finally it's exactly what i
was looking for and those people are
willing to pay a premium
for what you're selling if you go to my
website you'll see it's all about belief
right
believe that oozes out of everything i
do it's right at the top
of every page of my website you can't
help but get hit
with a punch in the face of belief
and some people they love that right
some people hate that
you know for the people who hate that
though the people who hate that
they're not probably gonna be great
customers for me anyway right if you
don't
believe and believe you're probably not
watching this video you shut it down
within the first five seconds you bounce
to my website i'm not going to sell to
you anyway
so it's about leading with your values
because people who
believe in what you're doing will pay
more for it
making it super obvious and it's
attracting
a target audience who are going to be
ideal customers
who will love what you do and can't wait
to tell their friends about it
number two is have a newsletter date
before getting
married this is really important because
a lot of online stores
they just try to sell right and when
somebody is is making a decision to buy
something they'll often browse they'll
browse between
different websites trying to educate
themselves and figure out what they're
going to do
and they may never come back to your
website they may visit it once and never
come back and
you know leading with the values makes
it memorable but you also want a way to
build a relationship instead of just
asking for the sale
asking for the sale right away is like
going up to somebody on the street and
saying hey will you marry me
like the chance of it happening it
happens but the conversion rate is
really really low
what you want to do is date before
getting married get to know them
send some value let them get to know you
let them
see that you know you believe in what
you're doing and so the great way to do
that is through your newsletter so you
want to get people
who come to your website to sign up for
your newsletter so you can send them
information
and maintain a relationship and so when
they're ready to make that buying
decision they're more likely to go with
you
so get a solid newsletter in place date
before getting married and number three
is send value in
every email this is a huge mistake a lot
of entrepreneurs make is
when they send out an email it's it's
all promotional it's all
product focused there's very little
value what i want you to do
is make my life better don't send me
coupon codes and discounts and sales
offers all the time
send me value right again this ties back
to that top feeling we're trying to
create
tell me how i can live an honest life
tell me how i can believe in myself
make me feel something towards your
company if i
love your business and what it stands
for and you're making me a better
person through the content that you're
sharing in your newsletter
guess what i'm much more likely to buy
your products
and to talk about you and to make a
video about you
right so few companies do this because
they're so
transaction focused and it's a race to
the bottom
so make sure with every newsletter that
you're sending out what i want you to do
i want you to think of this as your
asset test is do i feel proud of what
i've just written
am i proud of this newsletter
and if you're not then don't waste
people's
inbox time you want to feel like you're
giving
solid value and the five minutes that
somebody takes out of their day is
precious
and you're going to be making their life
better so you need to be proud of
every single marketing communication
that goes out there and if you're not
redo it so in summary number one
lead with your values number two have a
newsletter and date before getting
married
and number three send value in every
email
believe thank you so much rihanna for
the great question for those of you
watching you like the video you can
subscribe to the channel
to see more videos just like this thank
you so much i'll see you soon